bonjour
damien tard elle est avec nous c'est
incroyable cette image elle a fait le
futur de france comprenez vous que
l'homme qui a giflé emmanuel macron soit
déjà libre vous avez 28 ans avant cette
ville vous et eric inconnu des services
de police oui sur les réseaux sociaux
youtube ils vous suivent et plusieurs
personnes d'extrême droite comme en
rideau les kane julien rochedy encore la
plateforme tv
alors je vais dernier excusez-moi de
vous interrompre je suis tout autant d
youtuber de gauche l'accord vient de
youtube
mais c'est important de le dire c'est
important de le dire damien quand on dit
voilà ce soir on se dit comment ce
garçon a l'air très sympathique très
propre sur lui voilà à pully fait le
président de la république qu'est ce qui
s'est passé ce jour là qu'est ce qui
vous est passé par la tête c'est très
simple je vous l'expliquais un mois je
suis drômois avec un ami on a vu que
emmanuel macron se rendait dans la drôme
on était venu pour manifester notre
mécontentement d'accord une fois arrivés
sur place on voit que la majeure partie
des gens qui attendent macron sondés
gilet jaune qui sont là pour manifester
eux aussi leur mécontentement ou d'un
petit moment d'attentes ils sont
exfiltrés par la police ensuite la
police commence à fouiller les sacs
chercher les gilet jaune et commencé en
fait à dégager tous les gens qui étaient
là pour m'écouter là bas j'étais là pour
potentiellement
manifestaient macro notre mécontentement
de manière violente ans a eu aucun
problème avec ça et un moment qu'est ce
qui fait que vous vous dites je vais
mettre une gifle au président je vous le
dis hein les gilet jaune sont exfiltrés
ces gens là sont des travailleurs qui
ont parfois deux fois mon âge qui ont
peut-être pris sur le temps de travail
pour être présent ici et pouvoir
s'exprimer ils sont exfiltrés par la
police tout ça pour éviter de faire
tache sur sur des images télé et d'un
président qui en fait en campagne à
leurs frais d'accord et donc là le
président s'approche oui elle se dirige
tout de suite vers moi je vois bien
pourquoi ils se dirigent vers moi il se
dit c'est un jeune j'ai fait un petit
peu l'idiot avec mc fly carlito j'ai
séduit un petit peu la jeunesse
française carrément il va mais ça va me
faire un électeur mais c est un moment
vous dites c'était prémédité votre geste
non pas vraiment je vais penser
peut-être cinq minutes avant mais jamais
j'ai pensé qu'il viendrait aussi pressé
minutes avant vous êtes dit que le
mettre une gifle au président je suis
dit pourquoi pas s'il vient aussi près
nous n'est pas terrible quoi qu'est ce
qui vous va je pense que les maquis
travail quand même même le mas qui doit
porter non mais non mais juste si c'est
fou vous rendez compte bon c'est quand
même incroyable de faire ça c'est
inadmissible
j'avais voilà je vous voyais cc c'est
incroyable de faire ça c'est le
président quand même même déjà de m
gifles à quelqu'un
présidant la séance je l'aurais pas fait
je pense que vous avez déjà mis pas mal
de chiffres le nombre de vieux bois pas
des présidents les présidents c'est une
chose mais c'est un an vit dans une
société où on prône l'égalité c'est un
représentant de l'ordre comme dans tout
le monde la liberté d'expression est ce
que c'est pas un peu commode de dire que
ce n'était pas prévu que c'était
instinctif pour éviter une plus lourde
peine est ce que vraiment c'est pas
prémédité du tout j'ai peut-être penser
cinq dix minutes avant mais je vous jure
que ce jour là non je te laisse pas dans
l'intention de lui mettre une gifle en
tout cas mais damien vous dit pas un
moment c'est extrêmement grave ce que
j'ai fait
c'est juste une gifle excusez moi
allez vous donner une gifle et juste
avant vous dites montjoie saint denis à
bas la macro ni oui pensez que montjoie
saint denis c'est une référence
royalistes qui a été récupéré depuis par
l'extrême droite donc vous nous vendez
ça comme j'ai vu des gilets jaunes ça
m'a heurté et j'ai eu un réflexe et j'ai
giflé sens l'exemple même pensé que
c'était le président est ce que malgré
tout c'est pas quelque chose de
prémédité d'une part un acte politique
d'autre part est guidé par l'extrême
droite une propos pour la dernière part
chez aucunement guidé par l'extrême
droite c'est avant tout guidé par ma
compassion pour ces gilet jaune j'étais
moi-même gilet jaune j'ai été sur les
ronds points après montjoie saint denis
un cri de un cri politique royalistes si
vous voulez surtout un cri en référence
à l'histoire de france donc oui c'est
dur de franchir royalistes alors oui ce
qu'un choix et si vous voulez mais ce
n'est pas particulièrement connoté
extrême droite le l'histoire de france a
été faite par les par les rois a été
récupéré par l'extrême mathieu vous avez
été très choqués par ces attraits très
pour moi c'est vraiment vraiment une
opinion d'eux pour nous aussi parce que
vous avez vous avez vous avait giflé la
france entière à 30 ans à merci bouvard
giflé la france entière donc nous par
ailleurs qu on est on est donnée à la
vous êtes senti giflé par vraiment mais
je trouve qu'on est vraiment la honte
totale de 2,2 beaucoup de pays parce que
vous avez giflé totalement un pays pour
votre petit tube personnel mais ma
question c'est est est ce que vous
trouvez que la peine que vous avez eue
très honnêtement qu'est ce que vous
pensez de la peine que vous avez apprise
on passe outre et qu'elle est très
légère que les autres qu'est ce que vous
pensez de l'aviron va on va revenir là
dessus parce que la peine la peine pour
voiler elle est légère où elle et elle
est au niveau de la peine de prison je
l'estiment plutôt juste qu'au niveau des
deux autres condamnations j'estime eux
comment ça s'est passé le grand camarade
en prison vous appelez les gifles heures
le mât conclave est accueilli comme ans
par les autres détenus j'ai été
accueillis normalement peut-être plutôt
bien j'ai envie de dire pas de façon gta
isolement donc j'ai pas été en contact
avec les autres détenus juste à bien
vous mettez la gifle emmanuel macron
qu'est-ce qui se passe les minutes après
ensuite je suis arrêté
j'entends les gens me qui se disputent
un petit peu en disant mais pourquoi il
n'est pas fiché celui là qui sait qu'ils
étaient chargés du filtre pourquoi vous
l'avez laissé passer puis j'entends
aussi crié prenez tous les téléphones
faut pas que ça sorte prenez tous les
téléphones faut pas que ça sorte voilà
vous êtes conduit ou l'a ensuite je suis
conduit à la gendarmerie en garde à vue
vous avez vu que le président n'a pas
porté plainte oui oui j'ai été condamné
par le préfet de la drôme qui a
démissionné lendemain de sa plainte mais
bon vous avez vu quand même que le
président n'a pas porté plainte c'est
quand même c'est fou oui après il a
quand même porté plainte pour une
caricature de lui en clair non mais là
on est un peu à vide il n'a pas porté
plainte
oui j'ai de la magie condamné à trois de
prison ceux qui portent plainte ce soit
lui ou quelqu'un d'autre nicolas douchez
n'a guère su garder les mains un
discours parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il n'a pas pris conscience de son
acte vous vous rendez compte ce que
c'est que de gifler le président de la
république que ce soit emmanuel macron
un autre mais c'est un acteur qui ont
assez des mots hacked off la président
de la république vous êtes conscient de
ça ou pas du tout gif l'impression de la
pub mais je comprends c'est un acte très
fort qui peut sembler très violent mais
néanmoins si on parlait de violence
c'est une gifle j'ai pas mes volets de
la ville régis comment s'étonner
de symbole le symbole est très violent
ça je lave ou après au niveau de la
violence physique il faut relativiser
comme un dévot de famille a réagi comme
oh
[ __ ] la différence dans l'indifférence
au bout dit ne pas regretter
non non je n'ai aucun regret n'avait
aucun regret non vous le retrouverez la
situation actuelle avec le passé ni
terre
où il y aurait un gloubi boulga là s'est
amplifié le responsable des décisions
dans ce prix
[Rires]
le président bulgare
alors qu'il est si
bien
vous avez aucun regret
comme un 10 par jet et là
je pourrais avoir des regrets peut-être
sur la vision de la france à l'étranger
néanmoins j'ai reçu beaucoup beaucoup de
soutien notamment de l'étranger qui ont
su distinguo entre le président de la
république et le peuple français vous
auriez eu le même courage aux états unis
ou en russie
même courage de répondre sous qualifié
cet acte de courage mais pour moi c'est
mais il ya aucun courage j'ai juste été
moi-même en fait à ce moment là j'ai vu
quelque chose d' indigne j'ai vu des
gens qui ont été privés d'expression et
moi j'ai trouvé ça inadmissible à chaque
fois que tu mets à chaque fois mis les
indignés tu mets des baffes je vais
t'emmener dans les endroits où il ya de
quoi états ils attendent que tu mettes
des baffes vraiment qu'est ce tu penses
toi de ça pour moi voilà moi pour moi
j'aime bien la démocratie vous n'êtes
pas contents du président vous allez
voter tous allés voter pour lui qui
voulait dégager et puis vous pouvez vous
indigner ya aussi un problème à l'est il
a fait plaisir à plein de gens parce que
dans la cac qui l'a mis là fait plaisir
à plein de gens là les comptes avec sa
chemise avec ses cheveux longs ce n'est
pas des chèvres et il nous raconte que
quand il regrette pas non mais attends
je vais continuer mais tu essaies buback
c'est grave ce qu'il a fait parce qu'il
ya des gens moi y est un exemple trop
facile à gérer
c'est pas bien ce qu'il a fait déjà il
regrette pas et c'est les institutions
que tu insultes la france on s'est fait
traité d'abruti dans le monde entier
juste parce que tu as mis ta petite
gifle de bouffon parce que pour moi tu
es un petit bouffon de cour d'école
excuses à
tous ceux
qui soutiennent ce geste les séries qui
soutiennent georges insulte à tous ceux
qui se tient ce n'est pas ce que les
gens tous les gens qu'on dit tu nous a
fait plaisir une soi-disant comme tu
appelles et gilet jaune parce que j'ai
du gilet jaune à darsac dans la croiser
un ses comptes à croiser un gilet jaune
en question je suis sûre garderie dans
une 2 sont disposés aux tarifs mais quoi
tu sais que j'ai une fusion j'étais avec
les gilet jaune mais non mais tu sais si
tu sais si tu fais c'est que derrière
après il ya des mots qui vont dire
regarde l'autre il a giflé macro il fait
le buzz il est chez nous là et ça va
j'ai plein pot 90 pieds dans la version
c'est satan sur pied tu es un guignol
mon pote est un guignol moi j'ai envie
je vois que tu devrais g par jour
[Applaudissements]
c'est bien voyez c'est comme dans la
politique les paroles c'est bien mais
les actes ne se sont jamais de la
politique tu es partie plongée pas faire
la politique non non j'ai pas vu les
styles les anglais de sale damian
question juste été moi même
que je m'en bats d'indignation pour moi
la vraie violence elle est là à regarder
est ce qu'on peut parler ici bas parce
qu'on peut s'exprimer alors fait déjà
six et moi je te vois même pas et aussi
le plat héros s'il te plaît s'il te
plaît tu te calmes un peu tu laisses
réponse vers ça mais c'est vrai je tiens
à l'apprendre la gifle en version
wii alors damien je te plaît là oh oui
moi je pense qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans
une république et qui a été conçu pour
faire appel au référendum et aujourd'hui
on ne fait plus appel au référendum et
dans conduit flèche
moyen d'expression quand on explique
tous les manifestants aujourd'hui va
sacrer plus de deux ans que tous les
week-ends ya manifestations en france
quelles sont les conséquences sur la
politique aucune damien juste juste je
t'explique regarde voilà jeté les s'est
exprimé tour est très bien pu aller voir
le chef de l'état veut dire voilà
monsieur mâcon je suis pas d'accord avec
ce que vous faites avec les gilet jaune
vous avez exfiltré prévu que tu aurais
pu lui parler il est allé coûte quand il
vient vous voir pour vous écoutez là la
gifle est ce que c'est pas un coup
d'éclat vis-à-vis de tes potes vis-à-vis
des mecs
j'ai juste été moi même j'ai juste vu
qu'un kg avec jérôme a été indigne mais
non non c'est la première fois que je
mets sur 1,15 ou si vous voulez non
c'est la première fois que tu as mis sur
président non j'en ai déjà me mets
jamais une personne qui représente
l'état et encore moins
mais question qu'est ce qui te passe
dans ta tête quand tu dis cinq minutes
avant je me suis jumet tunisie qu'est ce
que tu t'es dit c'est ça que j'ai envie
de savoir tu t'es dit eni va venir vers
moi s'il vient vers nous je vais le
gifler non je me suis dit peut-être que
vu qu'il nous écoute pas ça fera
peut-être réagir que le peuple de france
n'ait pas écouté d'accord
faut savoir c'est qu'ils perdent la face
à face à l'arrivée si vous n'êtes pas
plus ce peuple que non mais je suis là
dans sa patrie je vous demande si vous
voulez savoir aujourd'hui c'est ce jour
là c'était moi me serais peut être
n'importe qui il ya un filtre de
manifestants à chaque fois qu'il se
déplace qui est monstrueux et
aujourd'hui c'est moi qui vais patienter
mailles du filet mais ça aurait pu être
n'importe qui n'importe que les
manifestants voulaient les gifler
énormément j'ai reçu énormément de
messages de soutien en prison j'ai reçu
des centaines de savoir à qui on a
affaire quand mr bernard monte alors
jusqu'à moi comme une agression à qui on
a affaire il se prend pour un chevalier
le geste il a rien de cheval reste je
suis désolé vous prenez toujours pour un
chevalier je sais pas vous mais si un
chômeur il s'appelle un soufflet
monsieur oui et alors et alors vous êtes
fier de ça c'est chevaleresque de filet
il a soufflé ben plus que je trouve il
est très apprêtée visite des sites
révisionniste il a envoyé pour s'amuser
des photos de moustache d'hitler à tous
ses potes afin de dire le mec il est pas
quand même clair ça je dois dire plutôt
très très à droite vous nier ça c'est
pas vrai ce que j'aime bien je suis je
vois pas ce que voulait dire par
moustache d'hitler
photo à tous vos copains avec des boots
avis clair avec vous un collège dit
claire ouais c'est à dire cela cris mais
avec la moustache d'hitler il a essayé
moi dans ma seulement en train de me
raser ça c'est ça que vous avez vous
fait le stage c'est drôle vous mariez
vous êtes très à droite moi je sais pas
ce que c'est mais touchable est très
adroit et moi je vous le dis vous êtes
très à droite alors que je connais c'est
monsieur très bon le se voit je soyez
honnêtes voie générale est de droite un
comportement malhonnête monsieur votre
profil est quand même particulier où il
avait été proche et de logiquement de
l'action française c'est un geste
politique voyant avec son français mais
vous avez voulu avoir votre heure de
gloire au nom de droite en frappant le
président
au salon
du coup j'en ai justement dit quoi le
président il a dit le président savait
rien vous avez quoi des infos sur le
président et brigitte à l'upr pour le
président oui bien sûr ben est une façon
d qui se déplacent ils ont peur parce
que tout ça ça peut arriver étant donné
que d'ailleurs cette quand il est allé
voir ce groupe il n'était pas prévu du
tout il a surpris tout le monde oui
c'est vrai lui-même surpris moi je
pensais pas qu'ils allaient en
concernant là on n'avait pas envie de
vous excuser auprès du président ont
écouté ça serait une double humiliation
que de m'excuser d'avoir mis une gifle
quand même et vous suivez toujours des
soins psychologiques pour mesrine mais
je commence y at il si vous voulez vous
suivait des soins psychologiques ou par
lala l'allégation de l'esprit j'ai une
obligation soit la foule à venette fait
quadrim actuellement je reconversion
professionnelle je suis étudiant en
événementiel d'accord mais ça va pas
vous bloquez pour la suite pour
l'événementiel je crois que tu es
peut-être
je sais pas quand je vais où je pourrai
toujours à moi et me débrouiller j'ai
reçu beaucoup d'offres d'emploi c'est
moi moi je vous dire moi je suis pour le
débat ici je suis toujours pour laisser
la parole à tout le monde là franchement
j'aurais aimé que vous veniez que vous
me disiez j'ai peut-être fait une
connerie voilà j'aurais peut-être dû
discuter avec lui ce sujet là d'accord
moi je suis voilà ici on n'est pas
d'accord avec plein de choses mais je
vois la dissolution le dit oui mais là
vous démarrez mal quand tu veux discuter
quelqu'un tue des pagnes tu peux pas une
tare direct non mais c'est vrai je crois
que jamais les six ont été rossés ouais
c'est sûr mais mais c'est vrai que parce
que quand je le vois quand j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas un ne s'est
pas un illuminé tu vois pas donc c'est
sympa c'est que il est il a fait ça si
avant gardisme d'accord et qui est
qu'ils en mai et qui ça veut dire non
mais ça veut dire qu'il regrette pas et
c'est ça qui me fait peur vous avez des
réseaux sociaux vous interagissez avec
des gens qui vous soutiennent vous
répondait volontiers aux questions des
journalistes vous venez sur des plateaux
télé est ce que vous avez pas fait ça
pour devenir célèbre est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous comptez vous lancer
en politique par exemple non pas du tout
je n'aime pas me lancer en politique je
n'ai pas fait ça pour devenir célèbre je
vais juste oui peut-être écrit un livre
tout à l'heure mais non pas devenir
célèbre mais c'est dramatique ça veut
dire les maîtres qui nous regardent la
folie flins même pour écrire un livre
il y en a plein qui écrivent ils
moi je pense que c'est un geste qui
inspira lait ne sais pas je pense à la
balle à blanc mais il ya d'autres moyens
de sa mauvaise et que j'en sais c'est la
haine excusez-moi j'ai reçu aucune
gifle à quelqu'un ça et vous rendez
compte quand même que dans les écoles
ils ont été obligés quand même
d'expliquer aux élèves sensibilisés
lettre pour expliquer cet acte parce que
c'est quand même le sommet de l'état que
vous avez touché ce jour là moi ce qui
me rend enfin je ne vous comprends pas
cher qui n'est pas un moment donné un
truc de dire ouais j'ai fait une
connerie j'étais impulsif rend plus vous
dit représenter un gilet jaune mais les
giguère aucun gilet jouée à pas de
chance les jeunes ils sont arrivés ici
ils ont démarré ici ce sont des
solutions sur ce pays
ils ont démarré
il saisit médiatiquement le il ne les
condamne ces violences ils sont tous au
violent ce sont des gens qui ont envie
de se faire entendre bien se faire
entendre
un
exemple pour la france et là j'ai mal à
mon pays quand je vous vois aujourd'hui
avoir aucun regret sur ce que vous avez
fait ne serait-ce que pour les jeunes
qui regardent des pmp puisqu'ils sont
très nombreux ce soir voilà je suis
désolé c'est honteux damien
ça va être quoi la suite pour maintenant
ben je vais finir les études et puis
quatre emplois
[Rires]
quoi vous témoigner comme ça maintenant
dit la vérité quoi je choisis je les
voyais ouais parce que je pense que
c'est un geste qui représente quoi qu'en
disent les gens du plateau télé la
colère beaucoup de personnes mettant
mais la colère on l'entend tout à fait
damien et on en parle très souvent sur
ce bateau on a fait de nombreuses
émissions mais la gifle c'est sur les
conséquences politiques et la jfp ça a
été contre-productif
je vous le dis que ce serait mieux à
faire dans les quartiers il ya plein de
gens qui sont en colère parce que c'est
le bordel parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
dormir puisque les mecs qui font de la
bécane parce qu'ils brûlent des
poubelles je vais tomber dans les
quartiers tu vas gifle et ceux qui font
ce qu'ils foutent le bordel ça
m'intéresse ou pas moi je le connais je
sais comment ça se passe c'est karama
ouais bah ouais mais c'est sympa
président qui vient non mais je suis
pour le dialogue ça n'avait pas compris
vous pensez que je veux gifle et toutes
les personnes qui sont d accord avec moi
c'est ça que vous pensez après alors ces
cas là non je crois que les jaunes ont
déjà beaucoup exprimé le dire rien à
voir avec les chefs du jaune alors le
peuple français